[Music]
it wasn't but by
a few inches but
i thought it was it was legitimate he
was it looked like
on the angle of our camera at least that
he might have been off by that
normally you're warned and the coach is
warned if somebody's doing that um
before they before they throw in a game
with that magnitude but
um they did and uh
he didn't waste any time doing it he
didn't wait till the interception to
throw he had his hand on his
flag right from the get-go
andy reid talking about that key offside
penalty on d ford who was lined up in
the neutral zone and peter watching the
game at home that you could see the flag
on the ground at the snap it wasn't the
typical they throw it straight up in the
it was just he knew it was coming and he
just threw it straight down to the
ground and and i knew that that was a
free play probably uh you know and tom
brady probably had no idea that it was
coming or he would have thrown the ball
down the field but be that as it may
that play
i don't know that i agree with the idea
that you should get a warning d ford
himself said on monday look i i can't
expect a warning there i need to line up
in the right spot and uh reed also
complained about the roughing the passer
penalty and and he was i think a little
more forceful in his concerns about that
one that kept the drive alive for the
patriots or helped fuel the drive when
the patriots were down by uh three or
four points in the fourth quarter and uh
the replay made it obvious that chris
jones did not
hit tom brady in the head even though
clete blakeman concluded he did but the
couple of bad calls not as bad as ram
saints but a couple of questionable
calls coming out of that chiefs patriots
game
the you know the worst thing the clete
blakeman mistake on that is that you're
always told and you ask any official
you're always told don't assume
that a foul happened you have to see
the foul happen and clete blakeman
assumed
that chris jones raked his hand over the
face and face mask of tom brady judging
by what he saw apparently from behind
and he didn't do it it was a terrible
call now as far as the d ford call i had
a bunch of people email me
uh
you know and say why didn't you write
about the d ford thing that was a a
cheap call blah blah blah blah blah
and and as far as officials warning
players
very often during games a receiver will
go to the side and he'll look over at
the side judge and he'll say am i okay
in other words am i either on the line
or am i back enough from the line so we
have enough players on the line of
scrimmage
and and they'll tell them but there's
two reasons why
this is not correct in this case number
one
the the 110 decibels of noise there's no
way that a guy standing 20 yards away
you know and watching monitoring the
play of the line or 15 yards away is
going to be able to be heard in that
environment at that moment that's number
one and number two
you know you can't expect an official to
save you on every snap hey move back 79
or move back 90. you can't expect that
you know so
it's a it's a ticky tac call but it's a
call that was correct to be made at that
time
yeah the easy part of the game should be
lining up in the right spot they drill
it over and over again they do it in off
season workouts training camp preseason
preseason games regular season games you
would think by the time we get to the
conference championship round guys will
know where they can and can't line up
and ultimately as ford said it is on
them your point on the roughing the
passer penalty you know this falls into
that bucket of calls where if in my view
you put a video official at the game
site that's an area where that video
official gets on the horn with clete
blakeman and says pick the flag up there
was no roughing the passer and cleet
says oh i thought i saw it sorry didn't
see it and you move forward and and
that's an example of how that system
could help avoid a lot of these mistakes
and keep 15-yard chunks of field
possession from being given to a team
that just doesn't deserve it
no question about it i would be very
much in favor
this falls under the category of you
know in the first hour we talked about
the coach who texted me last night and
basically said the playoffs are too big
they're too important coaches ought to
have more challenges
in the playoffs than they have in the
regular season and i would say either
that or
allow
more
help
on video replays in the postseason even
on calls that weren't called to adjust
calls like that there's that one in that
game i do not think the face mask one
that everybody is screaming about in the
saints rams game uh you know should have
been called it was a it was a marginal
uh it was a you know if it had been
flagged i guess you say it's good but it
was not a grasp and control
call on a face mask you know on jared
goff but be that as it may there need to
be some changes made in how
calls can be reviewed and officiated
especially in the postseason it's too
important if if they're not going to do
it now peter they never will and here's
hoping they do it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports